chers collègues nous sommes toujours
dans ce montage et la discussion
d'aujourd'hui a montré que ça avance et
que nous sommes dans la bonne direction
et que nous devons continuer à
travailler dans ce sens et sans se
relâcher
donc merci pour vos idées vos
propositions celles que vous avez
formulées aujourd'hui
bien entendu nous allons réfléchir à
tout cela et maintenant je dois
m'adresser pas seulement mes collègues
des régions je m'adresse à tous les
citoyens de russie pour chacun d'entre
nous ce qu'il ya de plus cher c'est la
vie c'est la santé de nos proches
la sécurité pour ceux de notre famille
nos parents nos enfants et cela nous le
ressentons de façon particulièrement
aiguë aujourd'hui nous sommes inquiets
pour nos familles pour nos amis et nous
cherchons à les protéger de ce sort
terrible et peut-être que à certains
cela pourrait certains pourraient penser
que rien de terrible ne se passe et
certains ne voient pas la menace ils ne
la ressentent pas et même à moscou où il
ya le plus de malades 6000 personnes
c'est 100 de la population de moscou
mais premièrement c'est la vie
deuxièmement c'est la santé de personnes
de personnes qui sont proches
et en plus c'est le danger d'une
propagation d'une propagation très forge
de cette épidémie qui montrent que larry
le risque est toujours présent
et qui menacent des gens qu'on connaît
des collègues ce qui nous côtoient tous
les jours et ceux qui ont été déjà
repéré comme infectés qui ont été en
prise aux pit alizés et donc toutes mes
condoléances à tous ceux qui ont perdu
un proche et je comprends à quel point
cela est une épreuve pénible cette
inquiétude cette fatigue cette
indécision
tout cela est épuisant pour tout le
monde
en plus de cela il ya les difficultés
financières matérielles qui s'accumulent
et pour chacun d'entre nous c'est vrai
qu'on a envie de respirer un bon coup il
se dire voilà enfin tout cela est
terminé tout cela c'est du passé
d'autant plus que on voit par la fenêtre
le soleil brille et le printemps les
tout fleuri et est sûre toutes lettres
sur tout le territoire
cela est perceptible à l'extrême orient
en sibérie dans toutes les régions
et bien entendu c'est ce qu'il faut
faire d'ailleurs on a envie de sortir au
bonheur
mais je vous amis je vous en prie mes
amis fait preuve de responsabilité de
précaution et quel que soit l'impression
vous ayez envie d'aller voir vos voisins
vos amis vous retrouver entre amis de
discuter de faire des voyages
il ne faut pas se relâcher dans cette
lutte contre eux le grand navire c'est
la leaf est de
elles vont être décisives et justement
pour éviter une aggravation de la crise
nous allons maintenir toutes ces mesures
de restriction jusqu'au 11 mai inclus
respectons ces mesures de confinement
ces mesures de sécurité et nous fêterons
se sentent ceci dit la fête du 9 mai qui
est une fête sacrée tout là tout le pays
ensemble et c'est toujours une source
d'inspiration de force pour tous et il y
aura des défilés aériens avec des avions
des hélicoptères qui se feront dans les
centres au dessus de centres des villes
nous nous organiserons des défilés super
psy chic pour célébrer la mémoire de
ceux qui ne sont plus avec nous et nous
remercions encore une fois les anciens
combattants qui nous ont apporté la
victoire et même s'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de les prendre dans nos bras
nous leur dirons ces mots de
reconnaissance
nous regarderons les albums photos de
famille et nous garderont à l'esprit le
sacrifice apportée par nos grands pères
nos grands mères
il nous pourront chanter ses chants de
guerre et de victoire est tout ce que
nous avons prévu pour célébrer le 75e
anniversaire de la victoire
tout cela aura lieu il y aura le grand
défilé de la place rouge il y aura le
défilé du régiment des immortels tout
cela nous le fêteront dignement
une fois que nous serons certains que le
danger est passé mais avant tout c'est
encore plus important pour nos anciens
combattants pour la première fois depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale
le monde entier est confronté à une
crise sans précédent
il faut bien comprendre qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une situation nous
luttons contre un ennemi et c'est un
ennemi qui peut nous enlever notre vie
notre santé et à beaucoup de gens et
nous voyons aujourd'hui les conséquences
terribles de ce coronavirus partout dans
le monde et nous faisons le maximum pour
arrêter cette épine amis et le coût
principal qui supporte et c'est
justement par notre personnel médical
donc je vous je vous appelle tous à
faire preuve de précaution et nos amis
du personnel médical
ils sont en première ligne sur le front
ils se battent pour nous ils ont un
poids de responsabilité qui est énorme
ce sont eux qui respectent les mesures
qui ont été adoptées et toutes les
interdictions qui ont été adoptées tout
cela ça nous irrite c'est bien évidente
mais en même temps c'est difficile de ne
pas les accepter quand on voit cette
menace qui pèse attention grandes
paroles aux belles paroles et encore une
fois je tiens à dire que nous a parlé
des mesures qu'ils ont prises ce qui
compte dans notre société c'est la
liberté c'est la liberté de chaque
citoyen mais c'est aussi l'avis de
chacun qui est unique et c'est une
valeur absolue pour tous et nous sommes
tenus de protéger cette vie pour que
chaque personne puisse vivre élever ses
enfants se réjouir de la vie et je vous
rappelle encore une formule connue c'est
que la liberté de chacun s'arrête là où
celle de l'autre et d'attentes et elle
est plus qu'opportune dans ces
conditions dans les conditions
d'aujourd'hui si d'autres préfèrent se
conduire autrement c'est-à-dire il
limitait sa propre responsabilité
pas rien sans respect de la liberté des
autres
à ce moment là il met la vie des autres
en danger et à ce moment là la liberté
se transforme en irresponsabilité en
négo isme et même en violence sur les
autres et cela peut entraîner de graves
conséquences
et sur le plan moral ce qui est devant
nous aujourd'hui partout dans le monde
et ici en russie nous voyons en premier
lieu qu'il faut demander qu'il faut
réfléchir penser à l'économie
bien sûr c'est important et qu'est ce
qui est proposé en l'occurrence c'est de
certains veulent continuer de l'avant à
promouvoir leurs intérêts sans
économiques sont cherchés à réfléchir
aux autres et ils sont prêts à supprimer
toutes les restrictions et si certains
vont tomber malade et bien c'est pas
grave qu'il tombe malade et donc même
que c'est le destin ce temps certains
parlent même d'une sélection naturelle
ici mais toute l'histoire les toits la
littérature nous montre que si nous ont
montré des cas où les personnes âgées
des enfants étaient abandonnées parce
qu'il n'y avait pas d'autre solution
mais nous vivons au 21ème siècle et je
vous le dirai directement ceux qui
aujourd'hui proposent de sacrifier
certaines personnes de les laisser alors
les boîtes destin en fait ils veulent
revenir aux époques barbares sauvages
qui disent vous inquiétez pas on a connu
des cas ou dans l'histoire n'a jeté des
enfants des vieux depuis le haut des
falaises certains disent que ce sont des
mid
mais ceci dit des civilisations qui se
sont construites comme ça elles n'ont
pas de durée l'histoire nous donne des
leçons
rappelons-nous un petit peu c'est une
autre histoire les histoires par exemple
de jack london sur ses leçons de la vie
par exemple un groupe de personnes qui
abandonnaient les les
les personnes âgées les enfants qui les
laissait mourir et ce qui avait été
abandonné j'espérais que leurs enfants
reviendrai un jour vous pouvez imaginer
qu'on puisse une seconde agir de la même
façon avec nos anciens et nos gens
disent que non ce n'est pas notre code
génétique parce que nous avons appris
auprès de nos anciens aviv radicalement
autrement de nous aider les uns les
autres
nous avons appris la solidarité et ça
fait mille ans que la russie vit sur la
base de cette idée et c'est la force de
l'état qui est notre force nous avons
été levée dans les valeurs de
l'orthodoxie et des autres religions des
autres peuples qui sont aussi ce soit le
judaïsme l'islam le bouddhisme mais la
philosophie nous a permis de tenir
pendant des siècles et notre
responsabilité aujourd'hui ces deux
c'est le destin des autres
d autres personnes je respecte je le
répète encore une fois pour nous
l'essentiel ce sont les gens leur vie et
le choix que nous faisons
il est ferme c'est un choix ferme parce
que nous agissons surnom la confiance de
la majorité écrasante de tout le monde
nous préservons la vie des autres et
ensuite le reste va se régler nous
surmonterons ce coronavirus et haut les
coeurs nous serons reconstruire notre
économie le bien-être national nous
aideront ceux qui ont perdu leur travail
ceux qui sont dans une situation
difficile aujourd'hui nous aiderons les
sociétés à se redresser à recréer
l'emploi à nous remettre sur pied
et les aides vont s'étendre
elles vont se renforcer mais aujourd'hui
chacun d'entre nous à un succès a
remporté à petite échelle mais tout cela
doit être une lueur d'espoir pour notre
victoire sur le corps n'avait eu tout va
s'arranger mais c'est tout dépend de
nous pour que cela se fasse le plus vite
possible pour que nous surmontions
toutes les difficultés les épreuves
d'aujourd'hui et ça c'est le gage de
notre avenir
je vous remercie merci à tous